عكه عند الوضع في ايران بعد ثلاثه اشهر
تماما وتحديدا على وفاه الشاب الكرديه
الايرانيه مع سجين امامي لا يمكن ربما اا
الحديث عن حصيله لان هذه الاحتجاجات ما
زالت متواصله لكن الحصيله الوحيده التي
يمكن ان نتحدث عنها هي المعتقلون بالالاف
والقتلى بالمئات في هذه الاحتجاجات الى اي
مدى يمكن ان نشهد استمرارا لهذه
الاحتجاجات واستمرار الحمل الامنيه من قبل
السلطه
مساء الخير اهلا بحضرتك الساده المتابعين
الكرام بالتاكيد هناك يمكن بيانات مختلفه
ورويات رسميه وغير رسميه وحقوقيه خاصه
بالقتلى
المقبوض عليهم والمحتاجين اعتقد ان هناك
ارقام متابعينه ما زال الحراك مستمر
واعتقد ان كافه المؤشرات تؤكد اننا في
حاله تصاعد واستمرار مستمر النظام فقد كل
ادوات السيطره بات يتصرف بحاله جنونيه من
الاعتقالات
وتقديم
المحتاجين للاعدامات بدون محاكمات عدد
الاطفال والنساء والاكبر منذ بدء
الاحتجاجات في 2017 الذي يتم القبض عليهم
او يسقطوا قتل غراء الممارسات الامنيه
وبالتالي كافه المؤشرات تؤكد اننا بما
اننا وصلنا الى الشهر الثالث اعتقد ان
كافه الدلائل تؤكد على ان المحتاجين
مستمرين في هذا الحراك نظرا لان سياسات
النظام القمعيه الامنيه لم تجدي نفعا في
حاله نادى المستمره يواجهها عناد اخر من
صغيرين وهناك اصرار على اسقاط هذا النظام
الذي فقد كل ادوات شرعيته ولم يتبقى له
شيء في الشارع الايراني
تحدثنا عن وصول هذه الاحتجاجات الى الشهر
الثالث
بالتالي هناك دعوات لاضراب همم مطلع
الاسبوع المقبل ومسيرات واحتجاجات ايضا
كيف تتوقعون ربما طعام الاسلطات الايرانيه
مع كل ذلك المزيد من القبض الحديديه ام
يمكن ان نتوقع بعد المرونه في التعامل
ذلك
لا اعتقد ان النظام الايراني سيقدم على
اجراءات مرنه خاصه ان الاجراء الخاصه
بحل شرطه الاخلاق كان اجراء ربما هو
تكتيكي او من محاوله مرونه شكليه ليس اكثر
ولا اقل والدليل على ذلك ان حديث ابراهيم
رئيسي في يوم الطلبه اعقابه اعدام همم
طلاب اخرين واعدام يمكن محتاجين في اليوم
التالي ومما زالت هناك ممارسات قمعيه
والقبض على العديد من المتظاهرين
والمحتاجين وتقدمهم ليه محاكمات وهناك
اسرار على نفس النهج من النظام هذا النظام
متمسك بشكل كبير بادبيات الثوره الايرانيه
والفكر الايديولوجي الخاص بالقاء النظام
لا يعلو صوت فوق استمرار النظام مهما كانت
التكلفه ومهما كان عدد القتله او المقبوض
عليهم والدليل على ذلك ان النظام الايراني
بيستعين بالخبرات الروسيه من المباراه
والاستعانه بعض الادوات وغيرها لهم مواجهه
هذه الاحتجاجات فانا شايف ان ليس هناك نيه
للتهدئه لدى النظام بالعكس الامور ستخرج
عن السيطره وسيكون هناك امتداد لهذا
الحرام
سليمان المدير مركز العربي للبحوث
والدراسات في الشان الايراني شكرا لك